oh God that's so bad that 80 of the time
women bully other women while at work
if more women prefer male leadership how
is there a patriarchy of the modern
workplace is it time to recognize and
recognize the toxic matriarchy thoughts
question for the woman
what has your overall experience been
with female leadership compared to male
leadership in your industry
um so
starting here and then go around if this
if you've never had a like both genders
as bosses you can say that too
um well I've experienced both a male and
female management but I'll say I have
the experience one female management due
to Blackmail
um
female I would say they're more direct I
feel like sometimes Mel um
management or stuff they just tend to
have like a more standoffish approach
whereas females were more
straightforward maybe they're more like
engaging really I would say it was okay
it was good it was a good experience but
there can be a bit of like that woman to
woman kind of matching it's like kind of
how men have that
Alpha kind of situation going on I feel
like that can occur at times and
obviously being a female you know we're
very like intuitive at times we're like
is she trying to you know
playing My Mentor but you know yeah
nothing too intense like very mediocre
okay what about you two
um I've had by if I've had a woman
manager once and I prefer having a male
manager just because they're less
emotional I feel like in terms of
leadership
I trust men more and I prefer a man to
lead and a lot of older women not all
but a lot are a bit jealous of younger
women especially if they look nice or if
they have a lot of talent and sometimes
it makes them wish that they were young
again so yeah I just prefer
I prefer
um men like I trust male leadership
foreign
so I'm really lucky I've only had one
female boss and she was actually a very
good friend of mine as well and we
worked wonderfully together
um I'm 40 and she's I think 12 years
older than me and I think if you have a
good working
understanding relationship with the
woman that you're working with it can be
a really wonderful thing
um then I've worked for many many males
the majority of whom have
been inappropriate I guess at some point
like not physically but just more like
[Music]
um
flirty and you know suggestive you know
maybe provocative inappropriate did you
ever feel like you got like better like
you moved up faster because they were
flirting with you yeah I did and
actually there was one job that I worked
at in the retail industry where we had
uh a male manager and then all of the
other employees were attractive women
all of them and it was and very obvious
and everybody knew it all the other
retail stores around us you know they
knew that the old of the girls that
worked there were particularly good
looking and that there would always be
like a new flow of good looking women
um but overall I think when you're a
Confident Woman then you can work with
other confident women and when you are a
Confident Woman you can take leadership
from a man
okay what about you
I would say for me personally the
differences between competence and
incompetence so if you're a competent
leader you're competent and then the
differentiating factor between a man and
a woman as if you're disappointed by a
rubbish woman boss is because they've
been unkind to you or been overly
critical or been overly judgmental and
then if you have a mailbox that's
incompetent it's because he made a pass
at you or he made you feel smaller than
you should have felt or he belittled you
in front of people when actually he was
the one that was wrong so I think the
differentiation comes between their
levels of incompetence but competence is
competence irrespective if you're male
or female
okay what do you think I think it's 50
50. I think I've had good and bad like
with a male manager that I had he was
all about looks and then
my previous manager who's a female
she was just very laid back so yeah I
think it's 50 50.
was you asking the girls or just like oh
um yeah we'll do girls first go ahead
um I I agree with like what you were
saying about competence so if you have
experience if you care about the work
that you do whether you're male or
female you will like brush up on your
leadership skills
um women lead the home so
I mean I'm a bit old school so I believe
that like technically
push comes to shove a man should leave
the lead the home
but in terms of the running of the home
the organization the family
the you know like multitasking
everything else how things look
um
organizing the finances thinking about
Investments like women lead
um and I've had an amazing female leader
and I've had a sh am I allowed to swear
yeah you can swear I've had like a
really [ __ ] female boss who was a [ __ ]
like yeah she was horrible
um and I was really young and yeah she
yeah but I've so I've had both
um but men I've like and I've had it's
same I've had really good men bosses
um
or like colleagues and then but men in
leadership
I trust women more like competent women
like there's a something really special
when like strong women come together and
work together it's like Sisterhood and
it's rare
it exists it's not it's not a unicorn
it's not a university sorority houses
versus frat houses the Frat houses
they're like best friends for life
you're right like you're right men as
groups like Bond better like they're
Bros more like they are like they play
sports together so they do more things
as a group
um but when you like get a good mix like
I don't know how to explain it I think
that's to do with competency like if you
are a healthy person and you find
another healthy person there will be
healthy things happening
um so you know you're getting old but if
you're dealing with your trauma with
getting old and like the way that that
makes you feel and you're faced with a
beautiful young woman you are not going
to take out those feelings on her I
don't know it exists there are nice
people out there but it's rare I think
it's common though I think older women
bully younger women a lot yeah I hear
you it's like like mother via like a
mother-daughter relationship well it's
almost like it's only I I've noticed
it's usually I'm not saying all but it's
only if they're still single like if
they're married they're like happily
married they got a man but it's like
when they're competing with you yeah
that's that's what I found I hear you I
hear you and the that's the dynamic
between like older women and younger
women but there's also a dynamic between
older men and men in general and women
and if men see you as a sexual object
rather than a work colleague it happens
like I've been a teenager like groped at
work by my boss like did you report it I
didn't report it like I when these
things happen grapes okay maybe not
grapes but like when like you don't know
how to like especially being a teenager
like I'm going to college really I live
alone and you know I'm going through
things in my life and I've been through
things in my life and it it you
internalize it if that makes sense yeah
you feel like you've done something
wrong or you're to blame like I'm feisty
so like I put it on him and I like
showed him it's not that bad but like
what do you mean you put it I put it on
him like bro like it's not that kind of
party like I'm from South London
and the US
I did like straddle him in the cafe but
like I just showed him like that's not
cool but
yeah like when there's such a difference
between age and like experience and just
in general like even if there's not that
difference between Asian experience like
men think that they can
be inappropriate and that's okay you
know some men some men
most men because if you know you can't
say most you because you've got to look
at a woman's experience and you've got
to look at they do research like if I've
spoken to 100 men in my life and 89.9
you think have moved in this type of way
ninety percent of men 89.9 okay you
think 89.9 have moved mad
no that's not my experience like I just
wouldn't I mean when I was when I was
young I had a coach hit on me but I
wouldn't generalize all men with that
89.9 yeah no not even close I would say
like I would say most men are good men
like you know what you're saying do you
have any brothers
I have two brothers one which is AWOL
and the other which is dirty but kind of
good so so if you put your brothers in
the room with us that's four minutes and
then you put what Kobe said that's five
you put a blessing here that's six um
and Mary just left that was seven if we
put another three you're gonna say out
of those Ten Men eight of us are
inappropriate removed you're you're
picking like my brothers no I'm picking
no I'm picking up I mean you're assuming
that my brother's like are cool no I'm
just picking I'm just picking 10 men and
you said 89.9 so let's say not so let's
say out of 10 men yeah nine of them yeah
are men that commit essay and don't know
how to treat women is that what you're
saying so I'm not saying that they
commit sa I never said they were commit
to say I'm saying inappropriate so okay
so okay it's the same way that he said
that older women may like try and put
that on a woman and bring out like their
issues that they have about getting
older and a young woman being
threatening to them
that's one dynamic between an older
woman and a younger woman an older or a
similar age man and a woman from my
experience so I'm not saying in life in
general this is for everybody but from
my experience over 50 closer towards 89.
okay it has been inappropriate can you
define can you define an appropriate so
like passes like like what's passes yeah
so you just mean like you look like
looking at your blouse like all like do
you know what I mean like like I can
give a good example why yes please thank
you because I was at work sorry I could
give a good example I forgot my micro so
far away
um I was at work um one day and I was
like going through my shift my job is
one of those jobs where you get there I
don't really wear my uniform to work
because I didn't like to commit in my
uniform so I'll change when I get there
whatever not so I've gone on the shop
floor and I'm just getting on with my
job I've got probably 11 hour shift just
going through it going through going
through it and one of the like new kind
of old ish like you know when someone
does a job and they come back we had
like someone that had come back to the
shop and they was like on the pathway
ever not doing their job and I'm just
like you know on the shop floor getting
on with everything I'm seeing them
gesture at me like kind of like glaring
towards me and I'm thinking who who is
it um this is a lack safe and it's a
runner like I work in Hospitality so oh
okay so like say something like head
waitress that's my position senior
waitress on the shop floor and I'm just
doing my day-to-day like you know
dividends and they was doing their job
but it's like they was glaring at me at
a point I was thinking um how can I help
I'm kind of like not saying nothing I'm
kind of looking at them like and it's
it's two guys no it's one guy this one
okay one guy this is just somebody
that's not necessarily on a higher
hierarchy hierarchy and establishment
but it doesn't make a difference like
men Mel whatever so um yeah he's glaring
at me and I'm looking back like how can
I help and he's kind of like looked down
because obviously being a female you'll
be conscious of when I'm when a male's
looking at you this is what I thought
I'm Stephanie's trying to explain like
you know when someone's kind of giving
you kind of like not uncomfortableness
but I'm not sure what you're trying to
say but you're not saying nothing so
you're leaving it out in the open so
I've had to try and interpretate what
he's looking at so I've looked down and
my flies are undone when was you gonna
say something because you've been
looking at my front for a very long time
maybe you've been looking at my crotch
and when I made like the you know the
announcement of like oh like was you not
gonna say anything he was like I liked
it like what does that mean he was
hitting on you but that's the point like
why why is that something that you know
it's weird it's just weird and guys tend
to do things like in their minds it
seems light-hearted but it's very
serious yeah
I flirted with the guy at work I was
doing like a six hour shift with my
flies undone yeah but the thing is he
didn't say anything so the thing is you
have to be clear you have to be very
very clever in what you're saying so you
explaining for her but you can't explain
for her situation so you'll give me
yours right but what I take from this
again what I take from this as a man
which a man's been inappropriate that's
okay but when you start talking about
an 89.g do you know what you're saying
you're saying when you walk down the
street 90 of men are gonna do a Madness
are going to treat you inappropriately
so then you can't then retract that to
50 that could be more likely 50 you know
a guy could maybe be like this or not be
like that as a man when we listen to
women talk like this we have to listen
to what you're saying and unless a man
has actually done something that you can
concretely say he did this I reported
this what we hear is just what we always
hear from women depending on what you
feel is how you feel the scenario was
but if you didn't report it if it wasn't
recorded all we have to go on is just
what you believe it is and you can't
even be clearing what you believe it is
what happened my response agree with
that like sorry but I disagree with that
because you're saying that unless
someone reports it you only have their
like version of events to go on yeah but
there are people yeah yeah yeah sorry
guys but there are people who do report
things and it's still their version of
events but you didn't report it though
when people report grape issues or essay
issues it's still he say she say because
if you're in a relationship with someone
if it's your uncle yeah whoever it is
it's a personal thing you understand
when you like people aren't here right
now there's a whole leap of people in
this room yeah but when your man
does certain things your man you know
and you haven't agreed to it it's still
a he say she say did you report it no no
I'm saying to you but did you reply I'm
saying to you that whether it's reported
but did you report it tell me what I
have to say I'm saying to you that
whether it's reported or whether it's
not reported it's still he say she said
and the reason why people don't report
it is because it's silly he says she say
there's no evidence camera in my room it
doesn't work right there's no camera in
my room to prove that what I'm saying so
why don't you report it
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible